this isn't a military target it's what's
left of the shopping mall in the city of
mariopol
ripped apart by russia's insatiable
desire to destroy
on the ground you can see how the
windows have been blown out how the
metal has twisted
it's hard to imagine that just a month
ago this was a busy place
full of life
now in the residential areas hit by the
bombs
there is no dignity in death
these are the innocent victims of this
war
some are laid out on the street
others under blankets
but they all deserved better than this
i feel terrible
i don't want to blame anyone but i am
disgusted
i feel scared and cold
i just don't have any words
terrible i was not ready for my life to
become this
they mark the graves of their loved ones
in whatever way they can
can you hear me
yeah i hear you
petro andreashenko is an adviser to the
mayor of mariopol
what is the situation with supplies
of aid first aid medicines
food water for those who are trapped in
the city it's terrible we haven't
anything you know we haven't water for
our people we're having medicine we
haven't food
we haven't anything and we can help for
our people because it's really it's
absolutely blocked for our for russian
troops
300 000
people in mariopol now under attack
at the last count more than 130 people
have been rescued from a shelter under a
theater bombed by russian shells but
hundreds are still missing under the
rubble the russians deny they were
responsible
the life is being drained from mario
paul as each brutal day passes
this used to be a swimming pool
windows and doors blown out
debris everywhere
the russian military see this as making
gains
of the donetsk people's republic with
the support of the russian armed forces
closing the encirclement and are
fighting against nationalists in the
city centre
it's thought that more than 3 000 people
have died in this city
managed to escape with his life and he
helped around 400 other people do the
same
i love this city what is happening now
is like seeing your relative dying in
your hands you see as their organs stop
working one by one their eyes getting
dark while you hold them in your hands
mario paul is a city completely
surrounded now
and there's a cold brutality to the
russian tactics here
and that is to destroy everything
raising mario paul to the ground
and crushing the will of its people
nick martin sky news ukraine